hi everyone it's jerry this is game
three from the 2021 fide world chess
championship match between yon
nipomnichi playing on the white end
and magnus carlsen
going into game three we are even
one point a piece
let's see what happened in game three
we once again revisit
a roy lopez we saw this in game one
where the players
yan had the white pieces in game one
same story here in this game three
play deviates from game one on move
eight
so let's get to that point
right here
on
move eight in game one we had h3
with knight a5 to follow
black pursuing the bishop pair white
gets a pawn
in this game move a
a4
threatening to take on b5
because this rook is unprotected pawn
would be pinned that's addressed with
bishop b7 some development
each side secures their strongest pawn
their e-pawn
typical maneuvering
with the roy lopez queen knight drifting
towards the king side
standard move as well for black with
rook to e8 bishop to f8
something to note in this position is
that when the rook is on e8 f7 is more
sensitive it's unprotected now one
attack or one defender
if white pursues an attack against f7
with knight g5
the way to react to this
well one way is you could simply go back
and white really wouldn't have much
better than to return with the knight
but black could play with d5
the idea being to meet pawn capture's
pawn
with not knight takes pawn as this would
allow
fried liver
like variation
and this is looking pretty scary for
black
you're in check problem on d5
but black could follow with knight d4
and there's pressure here
and now this d5 pawn is hit
three times
there is one cool variation i'd like to
show from this position
um
this knight f7 move is something i
tested out during the live stream if
this
position surfaced this would not be a
good continuation for white because of
the following
there is
after d6 knight takes bishop pawn takes
bishop and can you spot the best move
for black
feel free to pause the video
currently black is up on minor piece
and there is only one winning move
if you don't find this move you're
you're losing
queen d5 and black would be winning
black saves the queen and next can
rescue the knight
anyhow this this point is sensitive on
f7 and this
uh follow-up move is something you need
to be
prepared to meet let's say
in the game what do we have
it is knight f1 continuing on this
repositioning
towards the king's side there will be no
knight g5 anymore
flight square is in there as well
with h6
bishop to d2 negates any knight a5
with c5 to follow
so this knight right here as we'll see
uh
has some difficulty
there currently it's in the way of the
bishop and the pawn
all right
bishop f8
knight e3
and after knight e7
looking to get this guy rolling may be
transferred to the king's side as well
we have white taking action on the queen
side with this
committal
c4 advance committal y
many gaps are now created many holes on
the queen side
what one of the ideas with c4 is it's
not allowing
black to
let's say put this pawn on c5
uh we we have to address
excuse me we have to address the
pressure on it on b5 in some way
black gives this point up and in doing
so allows this knight
to take up a nice post on c4
and this is where it really starts to
get interesting in this middle game
when the knight is on c4
uh
black needs to take some care
over the a5 square this becomes a big
focal point
in this middle game a5 the threat to
maybe go there right now or maybe win a
pawn
how exactly should black deal with a
knight arriving on a5
something that ran through my mind
during
the live stream of this event
was to play the move rook b8
my idea being to meet knight a5 with
tucking the bishop away
this reorganization of the black pieces
is something we saw
in game two of this event
there is
an issue however with rook to b8
there is something i
overlooked which is this possible
sacrifice this knight doesn't have to go
into a5
this is a possibility
to take twice
on e5 and then there's a problem on f7
it isn't losing for black
but yeah it's
it's going to be a position where
white's
up upon
considered best for black is to give the
piece back with knight e to d5
okay
anyhow
it's not only about knight a5 but
recognize the pressure on e5
how does black offset the knight on c4
the knight returns to c6 keeping control
over both of these points
so these are these two knights are
really competing with one another
from here we have rook to c1
if this knight jumps into a5 instead
black would take
and this pressure on c7
isn't really an inconvenience to black
black could step up if additional
pressure is placed on the c7 pawn
this guy can advance
and it's unclear what exactly this
bishop is doing
staring off into space
it's not really an inconvenience for
black
however after rook c1
now this move starts to
be a bit scarier to black
so for example
if black doesn't do anything on the
queen side instead plays g6
now when the knight is here
and we have these captures this is
a little more uncomfortable
how are we defending the pawn
we can't easily get out of the pin
in this situation
so
what am i getting at
black takes some steps at this moment
here move 16 to prevent the knight from
getting to a5 altogether
how do we do this we play a5 ourself
the rook is now assisting in defending
against knight a5
at the same time the a5 pawn may be up
for grabs
and white has an eye on that in playing
bishop c3
possibly ready to add what's now a third
attacker or what would be a third
attacker 2a5 queen d2
uh from here
we have bishop to c8
and this is looking to
uh
interfere with white's attempt
to simply win a pawn on a5
so for example if queen d2 is played at
this moment
bishop e6 can be played
and
if white takes the pawn on a5
we can have
bishop takes bishop
there's knight takes knight
or
you know
well if knight takes knight there's
queen d7
and there's a problem here and here
seems like black will be getting the
pawn back and if we simply recapture
like this
rook takes pawn
we get the pawn back
so there are indirect means in other
words
to
or there are indirect ways to
react to
knight captures a5 we don't have to
defend this point directly
now this bishop to c8 move is leaving
black a little bit vulnerable
this square right here this knight on c6
is unprotected
which now allows
white to break in the center with d4
if white tried to play d4 at a different
stage
let's say
in this position let me make a passing
move
instead of the move played in the game
bishop c8
if black put the king in the corner
this isn't such a great idea this pawn
break
isn't there
because
after
these two captures
there isn't a threat of knight takes
knight
and black would be allowed to pick up
the e4 pawn
however
after this move bishop c8 the move
played in the game
this knight being unprotected allows for
the central break
d4
he takes d
knight takes d
no time to take on e4 in this case
because the knight would be captured
and after black recaptures on d4 the
queen gets to recapture and assist in
defending e4 for a second time
so this point is secure
bishop e6
once more in a position
to
deal with knight captures a5
knight takes a5
there can follow
not bishop takes bishop in this case
now that the queen is on d4 if knight
takes a5 in this position
once more black has a
trick up his sleeve
c5 can follow so this
in the end will not be the win of some
clean pawn
there's some
messy variation that goes like queen d2
bishop takes bishop
if knight takes bishop there's knight
takes pawn
and
considered best is first this
we have bishop takes pawn pawn takes
knight yeah it gets
pretty messy in the end it holds as
around an evenish position
in this
messy looking position
okay
after bishop e6 we have h3
useful
flight square
no minor piece jumps into g4
c6 now this is defended directly
we don't have c5 we want to stay strong
still on the d5 squared c6 is regarded
as one of the best moves
c6 or d5
on this move
21 for black are considered best
bishop b3
out of the line of fire it was
unprotected on b3
and now we have
d5
met
with e5
one of the things white gets out of the
way of
with the bishop being on c2
is this pawn potentially going into
pac-man mode grabbing the knight and the
bishop
with the bishop on c2 after this move 22
d5 can now
be met
with e5
and this is going to set off a chain
reaction
of captures as we'll soon see we're at
move 23
by move 32 or 33
uh five sets of pieces have been are
going to be exchanged
there are
interesting lines that can come about
after this d5 move there are captures
knight recapture
um
also after this push there can be
maybe c5
maybe the queens still stay on board
it can turn lively but this ends up
liquidating
right out of this middle game
into an ending
d5 in this game is met with e5
the knights
and the queens are exchanged
and soon the dark square bishops it's
important for white not to bite
on b4 this would only be helping black
black would be winning
three to two majority
not a good idea for
for white to take on b4
in the game we have
f takes g
the bishops are exchanged
in the end if any side is maybe better
it would be white
because these two pawns offset these
three
all right well let's just look at the c
file the c pawn negates two pawns
and on the king side this is where white
is stronger three versus two
king f1
rook b8
the rooks are
exchanged
rook b1
have to exchange there really isn't
anything better for black you can't
really play with still another rook on
board
if you try and operate on the d file
that's easily offset no good entry
points
exist for the black rook and this this
rook can maybe
start thinking about hunting pawns on
the queen side so there really isn't any
better than to
exchange rooks
and we're left to this
bishop specific ending where
uh white is
kind of up upon again looking at the
king side three versus two majority
but
the black king takes up a very strong
post that
is going to fully compensate
also keep in mind that
uh
this pawn right here being on a
light square
can always be observed by this guy and
because of this that will place a
restriction on
white's bishop it will have to
play a defensive role
we'll see that take shape
for now
the black king stands much better
f5 is a nice follow-up
ensuring that this king could basically
stay on
this strong
central post this dark square e5
so
after bishop c2 for example instead of
bishop c2 the move played in the game if
white tries
g3
looking for next f4
black can always play f4 himself
and
there really isn't going to be a great
way to make
progress here for white
uh if let's say king to
f3
i'm not sure how much ground white is
really
making in this position
uh oh i should point out
first of all there isn't time for g3
you would have to do something first
about the h3 pawn g3 straight away
there is no f king f3 excuse me because
you have to tend to the h3 pawn so
let's say h4
at this moment and now maybe white could
simply stop the king from getting to f3
altogether
play bishop to d5 or
maybe better yet give this check
not even allow the king to approach not
even allow the white king to put some
pressure on f4
it's very difficult for white to make
progress very strong post by this black
king
so from here what we have bishop c2
f4
black pawn goes to c5 so that this guy
is just a blink away
to apply pressure to a4
bishop c2
bishop d7 f3
uh if ever this move is on board
again if if if these two moves are on
board i think black does well to simply
hold ground not even bite not even
capture on g3 just being a spot to me g
takes f with king takes f and the king
is only improved
from e5 to f4
so
what we have is f3 king f6
h4 king e5 king f2 king f6
and these guys are just going back and
forth at this point after move 41
a draw is agreed to
and game three
uh well we remain level after game three
one and a half points a piece
uh is there anything to try in this
ending i don't believe so
so for example after king f2
well at this point right here
after king f6
is this something i don't believe so
because you could
uh you could take
and then get your king back to this
square
and if this pawn is here look at this
strong king post on f6
it's tough to
do anything with this strong king on f6
try this there's always the check there
isn't time to block
you get this pawn
so
yeah you can get the pawn on
f4 but how does the king
play roll
i'm not seeing it so
there are many different ways the
structure can change on the king's side
but there's never really going to be
winning chances here for white
the black king
will be able to find a strong post on a
dark square
and this bishop again will always remind
white's bishop you have a responsibility
this isn't just any pawn that can be
given up without it this guy bolts
so
at the end of the day this one
is a draw after move
41
and these guys are playing like machines
let's have a look at the tail of the
tape on this one and you can see for
yourself
how do you like that one
uh pretty much a flat liner
for the whole game
and that's as accurate a game as you're
really gonna see
uh we have all goose eggs
no inaccuracies mistakes or blunders for
either side
napomnichi registering a
three
average centipond loss and carlson
a two
super high quality play from these guys
neither one has blinked yet
but there's still a lot more games to go
okay
anyhow as usual feel free
to leave any feedback to this video in
the comment section below
hope you enjoyed it
and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you